one of my most popular videos is my
breakdown of why I thought Bohemian
Rhapsody shouldn't have won the Oscar
for Best editing last year so this year
I wanted to talk about which film I
think should win best editing as we
approach the Academy Awards this weekend
I'll take a spoiler-free look at each of
the five nominees for Best editing
discuss the quality of editing in each
film the role the editing plays in
telling the story and then I'll explain
who I think should win and why thanks to
movie for sponsoring this video watch
handpicked cinema from all over the
world at Moo be calm slash Thomas flight
you guys first up is the Irishman Thelma
shoemaker the editor of the Irishman is
one of the greatest living editors but
we're not here to give an award to her
work as a whole or just assessing the
Irishman's editing no have any moving
violations no do you drink on the job no
you ever hit anybody on a job yeah no in
the Irishman the editing is actually
responsible for a lot of the humor
that's in the movie
whispers Ditullio not the whispers they
blew up in that car on the same time
this was the other whispers the sheer
scale of the story meant that it had to
be well edited just for it not to drag
and while many people have complained
about the running time as an obstacle to
sitting down and watching it I don't
think many of the people who actually
watched it felt that the film was too
long for the story it was trying to tell
fellows editing helps us move seamlessly
between many parenthetical layers of
flashbacks the use of jump cutting and
the alignment of image and voice-over
and montage helped construct a world
from Frank's perspective the film knows
when it needs to clip along quickly
dishing out information efficiently and
it knows when to slow down so we feel
the weight of the story the transition
between scenes of Frank's work life and
Frank's home life helped inform our
understanding of Frank's character
[Music]
and in a scene like this one it's the
editing that emphasizes Peggy's
perspective it's Russell and Cary
baptized a new daughter
Dolores showing us her awareness and
judgment a critical part of the film
without her even saying any lines when
it comes to the editing in the irishman
one sequence in particular sticks out
Frank's Award Dinner sequence is 15
minutes long it features many of the
film's characters assembling into the
same room editing is used to show the
tension and conflict between all these
characters and how characters are
keeping an eye on each other
watch how Thelma expertly transitions
between two conversations showing time
has passed and how Frank watches on from
a distance he said that everything I'm
telling you yeah he said I mean who does
he think he is cache bro
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't need money do you it's not
about money it looks fantastic
but inside it's a lump of lard Ford vs.
Ferrari is a very slick film one of my
favorite things about this film is how
it portrays the racing itself more than
any other film I've seen about racing
the racing feels fast and tense and
during those scenes editing certainly
plays a role in constructing that
feeling in this scene the escalation and
eventual release of tension is created
through the rhythm of the Edit
[Music]
there are great examples in this movie a
fast editing that is good the LeMans
Reis sequence is over 30 minutes long
from start to finish and the editors
carefully balanced the race and the
conflict at the pits and the characters
back home watching you can really feel
the length of the 24 hour race without
it ever getting boring the geography of
the races remains pretty comprehensible
and attention to things like the actors
eye lines during the races helps the
conflict feel more dramatic and personal
this is one of the more technically
challenging edits of the nominees that
said I think the film has some pacing
issues on a macro sense leading up to
the LeMans race and while those probably
originated in the screenplay part of the
editors job is to iron out pacing issues
so everything flows well throughout I
wasn't a huge fan of Joker overall but
most of my issues with it came down to
the screenwriting the editing itself is
quite good
for example we have moments like this
scene where the decision to enter the
scene through a close-up and the choice
to linger on Arthur for so long before
eventually revealing the counselor is
the kind of interesting and compelling
editing choices I want to see in
oscar-nominated editing or the scene
where the editing creates a chaotic
unhinged feeling that we need to
understand what Arthur is feeling in the
scene
[Music]
I particularly like the use and timing
of these two shots from inside the train
which create a really unique unsettling
energy one of the strongest aspects of
Joker is Joaquin Phoenix's performance
and the editing really plays to this
strength keeping us in his perspective
and giving his character the space he
needs on screen to flourish I'm deadly
serious parasite is a good example of
excellent editing that doesn't call
attention to itself the film has a sort
of lyrical rhythm and pacing that flows
so well the filmmaking itself disappears
the best example of editing that we can
look at in the film without showing
major spoilers is probably this montage
chronica Tantus turn by mm Cosmopolis
you hi little fella bell career person a
good hotel and entertainer
Kotori token channel at all moo-hoo :
entrance yeah st. Anthony we jump
forward and backward in time seeing only
the most crucial elements and the action
is clear and concise even though
parasites editing is invisible it's
still bold in this scene the editor
tosses the 180 degree roll aside stead
opting to match cut between the two
characters to khmer surin didn't even
say what we're about to see search
officer tape and another my own crew no
more either Guapo but the rules are
broken so deftly that it's never jarring
editor Jim mo yang has spoken
specifically about his role in removing
unnecessary scenes and it really shows
transitions like this one she's doing
you swoon did you go to a table a baby
didn't mean I told you guys Shirley or
this one but not whose you can say
you're not on day
are responsible for much of the film's
efficient timing and pace that help it
feel all the more intense and thrilling
enough do you think I'm ugly yes
Jojo rabbit the only comedy film
nominated uses editing deathly and
cleverly in many places I love watching
a film where the editor feels free to
have some fun why people do this and it
doesn't break or hurt my immersion in
the story
Georgia rabbit has to manage some
difficult tonal shifts from comedy to
it's darker dramatic moments and editor
Tom Eagles manages these transitions
well
[Music]
I want to show you one of my favorite
little moments from the film it's a
great example of how editing can help
turn a brief line in the script into
something more interesting and
meaningful
[Music]
it's moments like this that illustrate
this sort of ineffable quality that
editing can have sometimes or just the
timing of cuts communicates a feeling
that would be difficult to put into
words
so which film should win while judging
between good and bad editing in general
is pretty doable judging best editing is
a fool's errand for many reasons
primarily there's no way of knowing how
well the editors did compared to one
another unless we read each script and
saw all the footage used to craft the
film if you're taking into consideration
how much work went on behind the scenes
you could talk about the difficulty of
assembling dramatic racing sequences out
of hours of footage for Ford versus
Ferrari you could talk about the added
challenge of crafting scenes around the
performances of child actors in Jojo
rabbit you could talk about the
challenges of choosing the best approach
for each scene from the variety of
improvisational performances Joaquin
Phoenix brought too many scenes and
Joker
you could try to say gin mo yang did
less work on parasite because of how
closely the film adheres to bong Joon
hos storyboards and the lack of coverage
used in shooting the film I personally
think the best and fairest way is to
consider just what we see on the screen
the timing and progression of one shot
to the next and the role that plays in
telling the story for me the two major
contenders are the Irishman and parasite
Ford versus Ferrari has the macro pacing
issues I mentioned Jojo rabbit and Joker
are well edited but for the winner of
this award I want the editing to have
played a clear role in what made the
film great the editing in the irishman
parasite are absolutely essential to how
successful those films are at telling
their stories without a deft experienced
hand the Irishman's massive scope
parenthetical story and larger and samel
scenes could have easily fallen apart
under the weight of their running time
or become confusing but instead it's
layers and complexities are easy to
ingest the pace only becomes heavy when
it's de matically relevant to the story
it's difficult to pick between the two
and I'd be happy to see the award go to
the Irishman but ultimately I think I'll
pick parasite the flow of the film's
pace as they increases tension and
escalates is flawless
even while it juggles multiple
characters over many locations it has
zero deadweight or unnecessary running
time no moment on screen goes unused
ultimately well places it at the top for
me as that it has a quality that the
Academy often likes to overlook its
editing feels effortless and is
difficult to even notice
with only 960 cuts in the film well
below the average of 1,250 the editing
of parasite is economical but incredibly
effective if it won it'd be a great
example of choosing a film with great
editing over most editing thank you to
Mubi for sponsoring this video movie is
an online cinema streaming and download
service that gives you access to 30
curated films at a time every day you
get access to a new one because of movie
I discover a lot of films that I
wouldn't have found out about or watched
otherwise recently I watched 30 a German
film by Simona Kostova editing plays a
very interesting role in the film as
it's mostly made up of a succession of
longer takes with smaller cuts to black
in between it's a slice of life story
that might be too slow for some people
but I think it produces some really
interesting and striking visuals you can
check it out on 29 other films right now
for free when you go to MU b.com slash
Thomas flight
that's mu bi dot com slash Thomas flight
or click the link in the description to
get your extended 30-day free trial
thanks to you for watching thanks to my
patrons for their continued support
every month my patrons get access to a
podcast episode I record this month I'll
talk about my thoughts on the Oscars who
I think sure got nominated who I think
should won so if you want to hear all
that you can go and get access to that
patreon.com slash Thomas flight